l'arrivée probable de la route du rhum
dimanche matin aux premières heures
florence arthaud est bien parti pour
l'emporter devant mike birch et darche
et laurent bourgnon le point de la
course avec xavier van der stegen
florence arthaud imperturbable à 6h30 ce
matin dernier point de course
elle et son voilier pierre premier
conforter leur avance sur leurs
concurrents immédiats à 15 noeuds de
vitesse de croisière elle a su grignoter
encore quelques milles à mike birch
deuxième et 100 milles plus loin
tous deux progressé en arrière et
remonte en direction de pointe à pitre
en guadeloupe
philippe poupon quant à lui qui avait
préféré contourner l'anticyclone par le
nord redescendre vers la ligne d'arrivée
fleury michon avance maintenant grand
largue à près de 16 noeuds et s'offrent
le luxe de dépasser laurent bourgnon
malchanceux notre régionales suisses de
saint brevin s'est fait prendre dans un
trou devant son voilier rm on atteint
difficilement la vitesse de 7 noeuds et
attention car derrière lui pointent
saint malo lionel péan n'est plus qu'à
soixante mille de laurent bourgnon
rétrogradé à la 4e place
pas de nouvelles de fuji couleurs skippé
par didier munduteguy arrivée prévue du
vainqueur dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche